it's globalization now about to go in
reverse so you know what I would say
China's the you know I think what a
business person does is you know what
you make and then who buys it right so I
just got back from Africa last week they
need everything we sell all over the
world that need always so so you have to
be in global markets I think the essence
of globalization had been changing along
before brexit and long before President
Trump you know I started globalizing in
the 1980s and what it really was was
shutting down factories here moving them
to Mexico for the purposes of having
cheaper wages that's ended for GE long
ago now it's all about penetrating China
penetrating the Middle East penetrated
new markets and and you have to do it in
a more local Flair today's movie is
about moving people into this market
it's all about market development and my
global journey
20 years ago you should start in
Washington DC now we don't really count
on trade deals we don't we don't need
trade deals to be effective globally so
we've kind of crafted what I would call
a multi local franchise that we can run
you know kind of in and out of 185
surely if I looked inside your supply
chain you know the amount of goods which
still have to cross borders within that
which at the moment you don't pay teres
on that would still matter even if most
of the final manufacturing I would make
it just a teletype what I would say
China's like we're like a twenty two
billion dollar exporter from the US and
we import five or six billion we move
sub surround the world you know there's
two times in business when you really
feel great like one is when everything's
perfect everybody loves each other
everybody gets along and the other one
was when everything's in chaos but
you're better than everybody else we can
navigate we can navigate whatever system
is put in front of us we would rather
have but you think the world is moving a
little bit towards the chaos but oh yeah
no clear but it it was going there
before President Trump you know really
time this has been this has been you
know the global financial crisis the
role of China in the world there's
probably four or five things that have
happened that a really seismic changes
that have led to this this bread
and woods version of globalization kind
of breaking down into being kind of more
of a multi local world so the pressure
would zero kind of free-trade all those
things WTO and world banking all these
things some multilateral organizations I
think that was breaking down long before
the incidents of the last twelve months
do you think that's fair I mean if you
look at the the way that jobs are lost
you know jobs tend to be lost by
technology nine times as much as through
competition yeah you you know you're I
believe look I believe in global is say
look I got back from Africa last week
when I go to Nigeria our products that
we make here they're life-changing
they're solving global problems we're
investing in talent and people it's
amazing how all the changes you know but
I'm not a philosopher like I I'm just
you know I kind of sit here and say look
I think globalization is a good thing
but I also know that there's people that
disagree and the task for me is to kind
of keep GT going forward on a global
basis while still being a good citizen
in the United States and and that's the
task of business leaders in this era but
if you were representative of America
you the case would be they feel likely
to lose jobs in the future you have to
cut jobs it's what sometimes happens
that's more likely to be because of new
forms of technology because of 3d
printing look I think technology has had
you've had a confluence of multiple
events right technology has had at least
as big a role as globalization most
economists would say that globalization
has created win-win situations but you
know we've got to deal with what's on
the ground today and my task is you know
since 2001 we've grown our global
revenue 10% a year I want to keep that
going but it's going to be without TPP
it's gonna be with you know kind of
different dynamics on a global basis and
it's my job to keep us going to that do
you think G would glow grow faster if
globalization was still in that that
first error you talked about well let's
let's take a really simple
we have no Exim Bank in the United
States you know all of your viewers
should say out loud we think exports
should grow that's why we've canceled
our export banks
I think that would be helpful to us but
we don't have time to sit and argue you
know each and every time that goes on we
still see good prospects on a global
basis